[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go let's show you that again
chiming hello
spooky time everybody with audio audio
what's up you guys Persia and Richy back
we're continuing our eight days of
horror and tomorrow's Halloween already
so this has definitely approached
quickly and I'm already seeing some
siren blood curse fans in the chat which
is amazing because Richie and I have not
played this but this was actually
recommended like I mentioned past few
days people were giving us
recommendations for games we should be
playing yes all over Twitter yeah so
this is one of them and I read a little
bit about it I saw some screenshots cuz
I was like making the thumbnail for the
stream and yes definitely gonna be
intense but I also read some cool things
some other cool things about it about
like the combat so I'm actually
interesting let's get it poppin fresh
game here let's go Richie I'll go grab
first you do a little research only
let's go
I only did the research that I that I
had to to make assets for our strings so
I tried not to go too deep into it who
normal going normal so this also on PS
now and it came with all like twelve
episodes I don't know what the
difference is let's find out let's just
go yeah chapter one we're starting it
dating everyone in the chat is already
like this games amazing alright this is
beautiful great choice and then you know
Tobias shedding extra affection is
Tobias good lord oh dang it's
buthe the guys that keeps like oh dang I
missed the first lap just now it felt
like everything shook for a second what
are they doing but this was an abandoned
village bothers me
they're way too close to them
[Applause]
[Music]
No
run you gotta run that's what I would
say and go get the proper authorities so
you can put the camera down
call the cops with typical nose
reception out here
there she be actress that you got oh my
god that's an interesting uh intro [ __ ]
forget the Hat bro psycho stock I guess
I should have put mature make sure
extreme I think we're gonna be everybody
the woman got stabbed tusks at their
shinga pretty good
Oh damnit where are the cops when you
need them Oh word Dexter what up yes
what is it
thank you for joining all right I am
Howard at least in this first part oh
yeah maybe each episode well there was
like normal parts per episode yeah
huh-huh no no no yes we started from the
beginning oh you might have to press a
button I think let's go okay there we go
okay just getting my controls situated
up down level yes it's already has wow
that sounds like something I don't want
to do I was gonna keep yelling this is
the whole stream hey hey what up yo okay
so it has all that like a scream but it
was just weird that wasn't scary at all
nope in fact it's help dead oh yeah
broken glasses
[Music]
oh no all right zombies I can shoot
weapons I don't know how I feel about
that get ready to run yeah oh he's his
aim is impeccable oh no a barrel at this
I know right that thing's ready okay oh
my bus yeah just checking out my buttons
here looks like I can throw a punch a
little Dino said please tell me there's
a ps4 version and remaster anything well
that gives me hope that those games
really really good first off second off
yeah just punched yeah oh she definitely
shot you in the face oh I think I didn't
shake enough y'all it wasn't ready for
that great mission we're playing this on
the PlayStation now yes there's no
remaster but it's it's yeah but it is on
PlayStation now so you can't play it on
the ps4 in some way that's what I was
gonna say before I was just so confused
by what were happening in it escaped him
yeah reach the house good I think you
just have to fight I think so too but
okay yeah yeah here we go there we go
please kick them all ease down tired of
this guy are we boxing we were just
[Music]
great Thank You Kino he says keep going
we have a thing here
meanwhile Giuseppe he's calling me a
noob oh yeah ruff all this is siren
blood curse we are playing a bunch of
spooky games leading up to Halloween
which is tomorrow our
yeah Burnett was straight up like a head
shot I've had enough of this guy oh gosh
me again no is an execution that was so
rude
okay so maybe you can't fight him it
looks like you just have to run okay
let's just try we tried to throw hands
you know we tried to face our fears and
go for it
this is escape doesn't say take him out
oh no okay Wow there was no way around
to the right yeah yeah yeah no no a
little bit in okay no wait he's control
there we go they take his car say keep
fighting oh no no man you have no no
technical abilities yeah okay you've
taken three shots at the background
radio that's pretty good
yeah oh oh boy can we baby right left
well this is how we know we're just
gonna die in real life situations guys
if we can't hop over low low-hanging
senses
nope
when you ran up to the I know they're so
creepy at the end Lamar yeah I didn't
need to hear that okay from the police
officer you can't jump down from the
street
what is let me I'll try again reach the
house as a sub-goal that's all he keeps
doing okay I think it really does want
me to fight there's really no way around
it
no you don't have to fight him there has
to be a way out
yo stumped by the first boss he's not
even a boss he's the first time guy can
take his car you are getting a little it
that's it I'm just gonna fight him I
don't know I don't think that's it
Darren says there's a hill to the right
siren is made from the guy who made the
first Silent Hill interesting Snapple
effect from any Ultima maybe you through
this place I don't think so
well you got your first set of brown two
bullets which he'll we can't see it to
the right let's see not right there
going back all blocked off what about we
did go in the house there's nothing
there
alright so we round in here oh wait was
that like a little around what the heck
why are we kind of like oh snap there
you go
just turn Oh Oh get out of here he's
invincible is ding he block your shot
yeah okay he says you have to turn
around and go up the hill on the left
okay just run away from him ran away one
more he's strong jeez I thought I had
him there all right I'm gonna little
invincible that's awful he's getting bus
stop okay thank you chat for not just
dumping on me and actually shoot me now
let's see if we can get it huh we just
find this hill alright so you think the
bus stop is that little like bench we've
been walking at you go the other side of
the bench and go oh maybe that was it
pick up sock a bottle oh yeah right
there right there here we go
Thank You chair
okay finally I was so narrow I couldn't
have done it without you guys it was
like us trying to find out how to get
into the cave yesterday and yeah what
did you try to punch him all afternoon
and then I probably should left what a
left okay so there's a head down there
or is that a sighting I think that's
another body oh there he is
okay okay it's fine I'm currently in
hiding mode oh come on this guy's moving
now we don't need that Oh
hopefully thought that was the bait and
switch now this says I want to be a
sport
yeah we see his point of view yeah this
is also interesting
okay so now you know he's looking over
there so maybe you can run now because I
can't move I can only look left right
yeah I try to shimmy out of these sneak
through the window of that same house
into the house through the window just
make a hard left
yeah here we go here we go
whoo okay okay so the instructions are
pretty straightforward yeah
thank you finest leaves behind I was
like that I'm got it Felix came in in
the chat and said you're gonna need a
hide a lot in this man okay good to know
hey that sounds fine by me because
sometimes oh maybe it's gonna do
something there we go some oh I don't
think he was nearby but this is good
just to know that this is a place to
hide let me get out of here let me leave
it will let me oh maybe because he's in
here okay has anyone seen anything
suspicious how is he so creepy and like
kind of like rational and if I had more
time oh the controller oh boy reading
come on we're supposed to find me here
right this is a hiding spot fooled again
yeah with the large gap in it okay all
right now we got a quietly sweep the
pyramid again those vibes though a
little bit yeah this parts interesting
I hate that voice I'm just waiting for
the prompt okay looks like he's in
another part of this oh that's me okay I
see how this it's like he can kind of
see you oh this one's really weird yeah
okay
so now we have a new prompt okay now we
know Kiran says run through the back
door okay yeah that's what I was
wondering too why is there another
stream and those colors the checkpoint
[Music]
making sure I don't miss anything okay
whoo all right a shovel Knight okay well
favorite pathway is it doesn't know I
can't go any down further
oh that's why you need the shovel oh
yeah this is for all those times you
watching Snow White
oh we got it all right thanks cool
digital TV says I really like this game
all right thank you thank you
we're learning to like it here this is
our first time playing this game few
makers like that oh my God why is there
no such a game anyway men such good like
and I could definitely see those being
remastered for sure yeah right CK how
did he not be here face it was
definitely honed in on you too
okay oh boy mission accomplished oh yeah
baby steps yeah indeed thank you also
for helping out we were a little lost
and I kept trying to fight the dude I
know why is there a child here I know
mummys scary but don't cry why are you
still wearing those glasses I gave you
who keeps present from their ex-wife
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing puts your life into perspective
than getting walked up on by a zombie
what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
I hate this guy okay well lot to unpack
indeed I actually like this is it's not
like like jump scary like this is about
pasty we can hang man we standing
children to the mix that's one new kids
yeah that's a big note for me
yeah I'm a head out we can get there
they gave you a trailer that was cool
you want to try chapter two all right
okay let's so we'll switch well assuming
all the episodes are pretty uh pretty
much the same length maybe you have
enough cable yes
[Music]
just murdered her like that wait then I
go into the room oh this looks like a
recap yeah
Dido after all that shot anyway
Oh be zombie yep yeah seriously
underrated all right turn here thank you
for being here yeah we took suggestions
from Twitter to play this game which we
have never played is this some joke for
TV you never know what those idiots are
gonna come up with right am I getting
pwned bro ah
Melissa
oh is it raining blood look in the tree
above you or the hill I think you're
right burrs that might be straight up
raining bluffin alright Eddie Eddie says
we a new siren game the series is
criminally underrated a lot of high
praise this is like the most high praise
we've had four oh yeah thank you guys
for being here tuning in we hope we're
doing this game some justice cuz once
again we've you ever played but we're
learning and you guys have been very
helpful today it's too dangerous so the
other way is like not an option a cliff
okay so oh there's some stairs there we
go she's like enjoying it yeah you are
to her laugh is menacing but like funny
oh great oh oh she softened him up for
us
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
phanie is Vinnie well isn't that
wonderful place okay
if you press it up on the d-pad it you
might have a flashlight what this guy's
the new character but yeah if you don't
want to be seen I don't know you need it
you can see there you go okay
[Music]
Kieran says the zombies in this game
retained their personality and makes the
game even more creepy yep they already
had a personality I'm supposed to sneak
past them right can i crowd
oh you can't great actually
[Music]
yeah I think you're looking at you
already learned the crowds before the
game well we are playing on the ps4 Pro
using PlayStation now this is on there
weird oh yeah that guy just got owned
and then he just shakes it off back to
work right the heck time is money
even when you're dead
[Music]
grab the metal pole what's the scariest
horror game you've played so far for the
eight days of horror freakin Slenderman
yes yesterday yep some weapons cannot be
used by certain characters oh ok ok
[Music]
we're learning here we go creeping along
there another one where am I supposed to
go back to that guy oh thank you ah ok
sorry I don't know what happened it's
good your honor you're on the right path
I think when I see your colors and stuff
like that I yeah what was that about
your colors I see I hear footsteps oh
shoot there's someone there Oh Oh No
run for your life bet oh and give me
your hand sickle cool oh we're powerful
now yep don't mess with me your powers
now I actually watched this Vsauce
episode yesterday about fear like what's
the scariest thing and they were talking
about how all these separate elements
together is what like really inflict
fear into us and I was like Slenderman
had them all no wonder I was freaking
yeah it was like science do they want me
to go back and destroy that guy and I
have a hand maybe a little exploring
will help this I'm sorry me hear that
humming ok maybe one of these
things in ha break the lock on the
mining officer aren't you got it
now that you got your weapon should be
no problem how about you Chad what's the
scariest game you guys have played list
it off we want to read them I played a
handful I'm more of survival horror
myself there's a different kind of fear
of like oh shoot if I die I'm gonna go
back to my last save as far as like
horror horror you know give it up in the
chat see what you guys like my ex-wife I
think oh no the one who keeps talking
about your glass yeah that's my gun oh
my gosh TK are you watching I Slenderman
stream this Morni is that what you're
talking about because that game really
got me bad good times
alien isolation yes yes I've heard many
things about that one outlast - what are
you alright woah you you're one of them
wait so it's magical dude is still alive
what a terrible wound can you walk
it's dangerous by yourself let me take
it and I just walk up to you evil within
we played that yes we did play a bit of
that I felt like we like needed a couple
more hours into the the meat and bones
of it though yeah there was a good
build-up but he started I've been given
a very special gift
oh I'm a living zombie what site Jackie
oh that's what we were seeing so your
special power allowing you to see
through the eyes of the shibito hmm and
other people oh that's kind of cool cool
let me cite Jack you Donovan says the
suffering it is one of a kind
Fatal Frame believe he this is what we
were doing earlier square to lock Ellen
Ireland oh whoa that is kind of grieving
like red markers are she beat oh the bad
news if Daniel says you two are great
appreciate you being here thank you
thank you
they're freaking everywhere it's like
I'm walking you yeah this kind of
happened when that cop was chasing yeah
so now we know or see anything
we go is anyone around okay you site
jacked her you can move all site jacking
someone's view to leave site and remote
at any time press else here more games
are coming in evil within the suffering
alien isolation PT decimates one beer oh
yeah layers of fear sky for him alright
yeah I liked hearing everyone's like
joke gam when I was like hey tell me
your favorite like horror games and
they're like Marvel 3 I'm like yeah
you're right that is pretty scary I'm
not gonna lie vanilla Marvel 3 why not
play Silent Hill shattered Memories hey
you played Silent Hill 2 yeah yeah
Silent Hill 2 was on our first day yeah
that was also another one that was
definitely spooky but I felt like I
needed a couple more hours to really get
into it
it had a big lead up alright site
jacking I'm letting her leave my eyes
that's cool
[Music]
hello
Daniel I so very much regret when I had
to delete Edie I know I want to play it
again sad times I've heard people are
even having trouble raising my pickaxe
oh crap oh okay again what it's have you
she's outside still right before there
we go you got it we can do without the
shrill violin banks joke God says Marvel
three is terrifying
it's easily the scariest personnel base
in the game that's fact
mad rush evil within - ooh yeah you know
and now like I wonder if how the second
one is I heard the first one was better
yeah a lot of people said live the chat
what do you guys think evil within one
or two was here or both like both
condenser first person perspective by
holding down our two you can zoom in and
out depending on how far our two is
pressed okay great
Oh Daniel says I really like the free
roam of evil within - all right this is
a strong one knock out the oh okay she
wants me all right there he is
say no more away I need a weapon Brown I
get a weapon want me to go throw hands
or you eat your own arms we have a
bullet wound right injured woman oh wait
I can do more damage if I sneak up on
him that was not very safe with me I
still don't think he saw you feel like
he's chillin
look at her view ah yeah
I saw something shiny over there good
[Music]
you just trying to punch in for work
dang he's just watching oh she's gonna
eat at this oh just wanted me to clear
the path I'm here let's go it's right
yeah oh wait I should let her be my eyes
Joe Vasa do you guys see the death
stranding trailer it looks pretty creepy
yeah that very first one pretty
memorable I went back and watch it a few
times I had to edit something and I
needed to watch it but it's good can't
wait for that
okay set a trap right there you keep an
eye on
oh you can't release her if you want but
I think you we like having her screen up
too right yeah I was gonna be using her
as an extra set of eyes cool that's a
unique feature now she we make you
something she's like no longer useful to
me as I exit out of her
yeah okay I'm like a little bread am i
dying
[Music]
wait did I pick up the trash out the way
lady I'm sure you can unset it right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what I think I just ruined my chance can
you do something here can we help us out
with another trap lady I thought it
doesn't run by this fool yeah what
there's no other trap I'm assuming that
ophea look like I see where you were
going there is another trap okay yeah
yeah I was like dang I love that pretty
bad
Arya's I need to put it in the walking
path yeah
and then now watch this superior beat
[Applause]
hey certified rub moment hey no don't
stop running yeah nice yeah yeah I think
these are lots more to come
whoever we're buying now is preparing
they got the shot that's a double barrel
yeah weird y'all get that yeah see
they're shook now b-body a sovereign's
aloha shotgun oh wait he's got to go
[Music]
what a boss
Oh something that you'll see on you get
into all right we gonna go save homegirl
I think
dude that guy looks like Sam Monroe is
that his name Sam of crazy on it maybe
that Sam dang I was gonna say of course
the godlike character damn just oh
that's Sam gotcha this guy I was I
thought you were one of them have to
find Alise
great he's close
[Music]
okay so we have to stop the door brace
the door or there you go there you go
stay out
yes I thought yeah go the door now back
up this is like zombies and call of duty
can't trick me oh wait maybe you did was
that the beat did he go back to this
door oh there's a bunch of doors I think
where is he oh yeah oh yes there you go
oops
oh sorry gal I just getting you back for
earlier girls sigh poll says both evil
with things are fantastic games but two
is probably the better go meanwhile Joe
says that zombie needs a bad child he
provided
[Laughter]
okay so Kay's family got a pickaxe
yeah let's just calmly go find a gun oh
I ran the wrong way yeah no no was she
waiting for a girl back now do you have
a good I know he has it he has it or a
pea pistol Whitney I wish those behind
you oh I thought that was thought that
was my ex-wife she was she has been no
help
oh gosh our area yeah
Jesus Christ himself in the Chad bless
up let's go Christ I get closer
Oh see he was right 38 caliber already
are done with l1 and then okay
oh this whoa this is like sometimes
racist stuff
yeah reload reload okay another over
there or is the music just intense for
no reason no there were like three of
them right well I drew them out on
accident last night oh okay okay okay I
need I need some space
she loved herself oh my they down I'm no
smoking right there's no lead aim she's
just in the way that's okay she's
invincible she's strong oh crap oh crap
oh she's in the way okay
I'm glad that didn't like and I know I
was like well that was straight up ahead
guys goodness anything did I reload my
oh can I reload and run at the same time
this is cruel so chill he's like oh I
remember this remember this game just
worked we're trying it out for the first
time God oh yeah help me would it be
cool for him blood this video what help
yo now your for you like outreach
alright okay so I think I have to hold
this down and then shake no I just left
me reload it when I'm out okay that is
cool Nate's games back in the building
also so chilled welcome to the chat
you're freaking yeah quit popping up oh
oh alright alright okay music has ended
oh it's back
you're doing great for you taking these
poles out so chilled ask is this the
complete series yeah it's one through
twelve oh yeah they're they're available
on PlayStation now we got it this
morning jump in oh oh I think we're
using this board that was very Indiana
Jones oh wait I didn't do anything
are you worried I suppose you can
navigate it for this side yeah look at
that see no damn it I think let's see if
there's another car over there you know
yeah where is uh what's-her-name
music is just so operating at least
sticking lunch
remembering the Slenderman you couldn't
run very fast
oh yeah okay I guess those are all the
controls you guys I'm drying on my eyes
from when you shot her in the head no no
you have it all wrong my friend we just
met before his getting bought for you we
don't know what were you thinking
bringing her to a place like like I told
you before just shut up
I swear you're completely useless I'm
gonna find her myself
come on
it's just like hi didn't see homie sight
Jackson zombie that's chasing her oh I
see Nathaniel so I was supposed to like
maneuver the cart to where the door was
I think but I didn't know that's okay
you made it anyway daddy said they don't
exist they don't exist why did he bring
her village okay which we're gonna play
right now
William Garcia says his new band is
called zombie felonies of it od
episode 3 chapter 1 let's go it's cool
there and we also like know where the
end in r8 skip names we need a round we
just lived it 3d heroes at oh no the
hospital part oh I don't like that
escape from the hospital
oh it's always a hospital oh and I'm a
child wait in priest or he wondered I'm
a child I know right I'll give me all
the door I'm just gonna open the door
oh that would have got me I think of
something upstairs Downstairs that way
hmm you don't have a map press on the
left side of the fence bag aha aha hmm
reception is not on this floor floor oh
boy below well the reception will
probably be on the first floor ain't cuz
its reception that's true this is if
this is a normal its building very good
purge I'd even think anyone near yeah
who she has site jacking to cool
well this looks like behind a little bit
she's in there I think get up kid
nope that's just how you least it'll
drag that out I wouldn't want to see
that no I feel like they can't do that
we don't have to know she died yeah
right okay all right so just crouch
under that oh boy she's inside and I
think so we can go around like straight
ahead yeah she's great
oh she's in there yeah yeah yes yeah and
we know what happens when I go in mouki
stuff okay hmm now says we need to get
down to the basement could we go to
reception yeah so there's like goals and
sub goals okay that does not look like
reception I'm walking would ya yes the
customer service in those please cease
elevator
[Music]
okay well I can't go down any further
maybe there was something mine here the
right thing I was a wall I was like is
that a path yeah candy maybe no way does
the elevator work oh yeah it does I was
joking then go hide in the corner so
call it go high and holy three-year-old
that's why I hate this bar yep
dude honestly I feel like after
yesterday I am invincible scary games
because none of this is freaking me out
as bad as that game did Linderman how
did she get there well you know her dad
was like all right I don't play hide and
seek go hide and naturally she was like
oh boy nice light Jack thank you oh man
he took the elevator up maybe you're not
kiddin come out no I don't think so he
was like come on out what if I yell
there you go oh you see my intention at
least get them out of the elevators the
goal the other way for a second
rats shot not you got this Ricky all
right
just check please I don't want to hog
all the fun okay so let's do that
I know what to do I'm gonna go over here
[Music]
she's so cute oh man do that does that
attract the attention of other lady
probably well that time it attracted
nobody let's try again okay it's gonna
be right there yeah well I think your
footsteps were enough oh I didn't you
know I tried to it's so dark
without the black you can't even tell
where you're reading to cute little run
yeah thank you too close
how would you go first
well we didn't try to go in that other
room where the other person is we didn't
now it's true not yet
maybe I should get her out of that room
first oh it might make it easier for ya
just sneak in there at first and see if
there's anything else in there oh just
join her oh oh Terminator the room with
the ladies standing in there I think you
can turn off the machine that makes her
leave
oh I just did it looks that was me
okay so now now might be easier to get
him out of there the controller stop
beat oh oh you have to distract her okay
my have to do it again
Oh your flashlight yeah who's on the
left hard left
Oh what the monitors yeah I saw that
light but I'm not why did i okay time to
run shoot it up demo but now what I want
the guy now now open up the elevator
because that's distracting her and then
run away behind those things call him
out she won't come Durr because
[Music]
I think we're on the right track yeah
it's like a puzzle yeah dang it
and there was nowhere in there that you
could hide it yeah so yeah here this is
my only area you staircase see there is
no staircase see ray it's all blah blah
um there was there's B C made me go
upstairs I think remember when we're
trying to find a reception so we went
downstairs oh right I think I should try
to see anyway see what's upstairs or
just try to get this done hmm
yeah we don't even know where the
elevator is going to go yeah let's just
before I mess things up here let's
double check with what happens if I try
to go upstairs
Amala says I'm a zombies that's a good
question they're like living and not
living and smart but dumb
oh no they're really strong - okay so
staircase C right because if he's in the
elevator you'll probably be able to make
him go up Oh try again you can do it I'm
skating if somebody didn't know we're in
there before I do okay there was an
option over here next to the reception
that like prompted me to do something
right here oh this elevator okay maybe
that was the button or that's what I saw
earlier this is one deadly game of
hide-and-seek says Vertov right right
yeah duck continued to duck all that
guy's gonna be in there huh this airs
about this good officer
dang it now I can't see if I go
downstairs what's what am I looking for
there I have no idea I was just like
maybe draw him out upstairs and then go
downstairs and call it but it looks like
one yet whenever she presses a little
button to call the elevator it's like oh
I think I'm gonna call him out up here
and then run downstairs hello
totally forgot you're there I hate how
the buttons on this side they do that on
purpose
[Applause]
hopefully he came out did he come out I
think so cuz your screens all flashy
okay now might be teasing nice to quiet
now I'm gonna try this out and wish me
luck guys
damnit there ride the elevator with him
if he didn't see me yo that was Arabic I
don't think okay what did you think of
my technique should I try that again um
what would you do Persia think I would I
think you called out that other one from
her spa you're right it was right there
my face yeah William that I believe in
you we kind of have a foundation of
what's going on we just need to know how
to get to you staircase B to get to the
first one okay
William Garcia said yeah he tried to
ride it with it
try to ride the elevator with that guy
woo yeah he's camping hahaha you just
post it up there he won't go away just
wanna see what she does
besides this job yeah this does have
some weird mechanics but uh it's kind of
cool to learn you know it's not so it's
not such a typical horror game at least
in the mechanics yeah okay so we
distracted her with that ah terminators
is here on the right track Persia
Terminator suggests sneak into the heart
monitor room but I sort of remember
needing to do something there it has to
do with distracting her and then
sneaking past her whenever she checks
the machine oh okay okay anything oh
yeah how are they so smart well they're
like dumbass zombies like dude right I
missed those guys yeah we could really
use them right now these ones are like
work oh shoot that was cool you almost
kind of way I know I was using her
vision to see where I was going actually
I was like
call the camper downstairs then use the
elevator harder than it looks okay but
yes keep the tips coming we were more
working it is our first time playing
this Amala yeah it seems like it
everyone is just going about their
business and continually working that's
right you're miles ahead god can't see
the stairs yeah the right ones whatever
it's going right we did it who use
staircase 8 ahead to the first floor
they're just making us explore this
against child Oh Joe I don't know if
they're actually called zombies and
zombies in this game I doubt it for some
reason there's probably some cool name
for them but ok ok good place to hide
very Metal Gear Solid can't see any too
small no the vents are like up here if
you're too little
oh that makes sense all right gotcha
look good that's good to know oh no
malla be not a dumb question we learned
what the blue crosshairs were what 20
minutes ago 30 minutes ago your
character in this game can they call it
sight Jack so you can sight Jack the
enemy zombies and you can see what
they're seeing so it's very helpful
of course I used to go
you got this Persia so far this has not
been to jump scary would you say maybe
sometimes the heart beats like that yeah
yeah that was the name they use the she
beat Oh
probably yeah not zombies but I don't
head up to the first floor oh yeah I'm
in the basement right okay oh but one of
the missions wants to go to the basement
right yeah so we went down in an hour up
and I feel like we're I feel like we're
kind of safe here yeah you did all this
there was more downstairs too
I don't know where you where did you
come from upstairs yeah I did actually I
think because the incinerator sounds
like it would be in the basement there
was a small staircase I think behind you
might be tripping like to the right of
that door oh there's more yeah okay
hopefully you want track here oh I can
see where I came from
oh okay great child thank you we're
putting you through the wringer here I'm
all in chat says it looks like a tense
game rather than a jump scary game yeah
yeah you're put on edge a lot because uh
at least in this mission you're kind of
hiding from all the bad guys earlier
though Amala we were straight-up
shooting them so there's a little bit of
both
and a reader Joe says I feel like the
whole point of a zombie is to be brain
dead is the brain dead aspect zombies
got PhDs dang so close to the outdoors
yeah so far only you can only examine it
yeah you want to open anything whatever
takes us to the incinerator man okay so
I'll get back to this because someone's
here
someone is here I'm here maybe try to a
site jack if someone's nearby oh there's
the incinerator okay you're on the right
board all right you know that mofo is
gonna be in there smart play though
using the map I never used the damn map
[Music]
okay so they're in that area that was
cool you think that want him read by
nature says haven't played this game in
years found it a bit confusing at first
wait there's a learning curve but we're
getting through neither of us have
played this ever and we're learning here
with y'all today so thank you thank
y'all for watching
well god is that her inside it stopped
it stopped beating I got the key did yes
oh she was hiding my dog
this Perignon take me zebra bar away
okay okay I know where it is now way out
yeah it's like rushing it down she's
just camping line that door it appears
like her vision it's like a door or a
locker
[Music]
see if I can see here now but yeah we go
off - oh no all right thanks he was
right there Joe looked it up for us okay
cool
confirm they are shibito yes and they
keep their intelligence and personality
after being reanimated very cool gibreel
says try playing white dude I'm gonna
let this child hide in the incinerator
oh I was looking at yeah you made it
into the incinerator yeah I was thinking
if I like that's that's gonna called air
force and I hear kind of you and I'm
like glowing when she has to be near me
from this mode can you cite Jack like
without - yes but she's I don't think
she's in my field of view
oh yeah it's limited in here huh where'd
she go
I wish you could yell in here no that
was a piece it was like oh that's poor
kid I know
[Music]
Oh antenna chasis don't worry about the
flashlight so I think
does that mean we're cool to use it are
like don't worry about using it I've
been like they don't see the lightly
yeah alright so I can see totally how
the site jacking everything like I can
see that they're not looking at the door
so I can run by yeah that was behind a
desk oh my god employees there's so many
new tasks Oh Lance in the chat says oh
they don't notice your flag oh ok nice
they're not be lying bro yeah now the
music kicked in oh yeah
all right little patience paid off there
nice job sting why do you come down here
I hate that it's like a chance or
somebody no all right as a be Buble into
the basement distract me with something
in the kitchen
pass through the administrator Bob
[Music]
this music so chilled said it reminds
him of an action-adventure game not
something haunting
[Music]
it's like Oh
the controls are weird yeah the the
right stick is sensitive Jabril says yo
that scared me
yeah hey go there you go
chillin chillin behind the desk but that
other guy was around this corner oh
that's messed up
hiding in the he was like right there
behind the corner oh that guy - just
calling your name that is mess up I'm
just a child
okay we know this one goes away
I do the white turn
what if you were like hey right now come
on go in there already read by nature in
the chat says imagine the Nightmare on
Elm Street game like this that'd be cool
it's like Freddy Krueger going around
haunting dreams okay so if that was the
guy yeah where'd he come from that
wasn't that was guy number three he was
down the hallway to your right yeah so
maybe that was the dad yeah but the
other guy who got you the first time was
around the corner to the left so it's
weird I think you're surrounded but now
it's all quiet of course
[Music]
really should I call them in min hi I'm
a try - yeah get them out for more
they're there just posted up oh gosh oh
gosh oh gosh that's definitely my dad
there is perfect
damn this place must be like limiting my
senses ding okay wait here a lot of act
that's not like a drawer can't tell dang
I wish she could psyche Jackie oh well
like you know a little further away I
guess she's young you know she's still
haunting this house that's true it's a
lot to take in right now for a kid
they're coming gaming a DS tap says 7th
gen still looks great yeah it's a ps3
game not bad for a jack in here he's
like right there and do it oh that's so
annoying they're like laughing out there
I know da hole someone that sounds
that's the sound of like a door
unlocking ain't alright the elevator I
don't remember if the elevator beef
they're making you you gotta get out
[Music]
he just okay could you hmm
so you are surrounded okay so maybe I
should try that he's out of the elevator
now right okay so I gotta go in the
elevator I think that's what that's what
it is because I think the elevators
right across the hall from the generator
okay
so honey the dad runs by I'm gonna run
to don't forget it
because elevator boy is not in there
nope nope
William Garcia says I wish you could
just laugh along with them confuse the
monster definitely making me laugh or
that one shibito joke yeah we're kind of
on the same wavelength they're like we
got a nor them and sneak pass on the bum
you get to the elevator
alright ladies going commit I remember a
horror game that makes you like requires
so much patience probably goes like
everything in your body is like run yeah
just run so so yeah let's see now we're
waiting for pops the dad running
passability scared me yeah cuz I thought
he definitely saw me I was like and says
he was like oh man where is he I think
that's him laughing no do I have to like
go out to like activate the animation mm
maybe uh maybe get closer to the door
unless it really is a timed thing but no
I mean you did it once where you're
hanging out at the door crouched like oh
there you go
maybe now this will trigger him to come
controller B I started beating okay when
I walked through the DEP yep there's any
like why don't I believe
I can walk into a stable zone swimming
back or actually I think he's pretty fun
yeah was he going the other way
oh no that's the one you're in there
that's the elevators so he goes back I'm
gonna hide in that locker
oh yeah right now he's walking I know
the dad's gonna run forward might be
rounding the corner suit okay he kind of
faced the other wall
waiting for the dad to Bob out no still
here somewhere
where is that he did go in the elevator
there is that is the dad yeah well he
didn't look into the room
nice Persia those a big move big play
yeah these plays these pro blood-crazed
plays right here of course he didn't go
all the way down yeah this is what
showed me that this is what I had to do
and he did that yes yes really getting
somewhere crap it's because I started
running and I wasn't crossing I think
you hear my feet oh maybe but someone
else entirely different found you
yeah so we ain't going into that door
damn oh god that's so annoying okay we
got 99 chapter 3
the chat is on our side possible
I was also panicking because like a
zombie was chasing me so yeah I didn't
make sound decisions there's too many in
here though yeah I think I really need
to go in there alright so what I'm gonna
do early on is lock in the homeboy over
here and lock in now
I'm in here wait for pop yeah wait for
Gil dad I actually think that Oh ray-ray
[Music]
cyborg man this game is a ps3 originally
but it is currently on a Playstation now
so it's downloadable if you have the
subscription or you can stream it
gibreel actually don't feel like the dad
yeah where'd he go here I wonder if I'm
envisioned his ears were ringing okay so
I think I'm like in Jack's site or site
Jack or whatever I can't feel the
vibration of somebody else coming yeah
cuz I couldn't tell when the dad was
coming you know what though there's
enough like it takes a while for the dad
to get this show up right like yeah rush
it down to that locker early I don't
know I don't know what I'm thinking -
does he know dad struggling with the
door over there
cyborg man good stuff hope you like it
cuz uh we're enjoying it it's it's a
little a little more I guess puzzle any
sort of yeah like strategy [ __ ] yeah
strategy yeah very good at perfect
perfect and work it out
I was like I wonder if she'll see me am
i just okay so I at least want to get
sight on them first
yes Oh shucks dad if there is a third
person now was someone like on another
floor I think no way that's rude
God you know it's the dad's fault the
dad is making this very difficult
Oh Dark Knight this game is there's a
little loose story here where a camera
crew filming something in Japan and we
run into these like zombies called the
shibito and they're ruining our lives
basically they're all over the place and
at this point we're just trying to get
out of here yes Japan in general but we
have to like be reunited with everyone
who was in our group at first yeah no he
the dad just died so yeah the dad has
turned into one of them it's all right
wait that's dad dad did go in the
elevator okay
oh how annoying for ever I think we have
some time running dad's upstairs oh
that's good so if we go now oh oh that's
the elevator
no work is it worth the tech real no he
knows I'm in there worth a shot we know
things now William says more like she do
you know am i right
he also says he totally got this Persia
thank you I think I have enough time
before dad comes out I just want to see
him I can walk behind her without her
realizing I'm here oh that would be Wow
walk into that guy right now now you're
doing the speedrun techno
[Music]
I'm gonna try to make this quick the
second he turns around I'm going because
I feel like dad's coming single thing
right he's walking past the lockers
gonna need heavy therapy after all of
this word oh maybe she's talking about
the case the child the child we got it
dad cheese oh don't look don't look at
me
[Music]
yes too long to think I did okay so the
second u-turns I am sorry
[Music]
dang
we still have support from the chat
thank you guys you totally got this I
have a good feeling this is the one
[Music]
Jack this fool not even shining falcon
says I'm reminded of the alien isolation
lockers do not help buddy else is this
positive reinforcement let's go yes EMA
all day hey the second he turns away
from the door I'm out I'm out with the
clouds yeah there's a little animation
that takes a sec you got this oh good
thing you didn't just jump on that look
he's still blazing you got that door was
that open the door is open a bull carrot
is but there was a monkey in there I
don't think he saw me I think he's lost
now I think he gave up but okay so he is
going crazy
there is a zombie in here
what's okay he's back on his regular
route back on his Brian so I'm gonna
exit out of this but there's
there's something in here I don't know
the zero hold up one year look at this
traffic so employees staircase I have to
go through this gate here but okay maybe
if I look around
nice I checked through a door oh please
let me do the cage they can't get to me
from there yeah I think that was the
same one yep it was
I see cracking for Mari somebody say the
game he ran through the through the room
and was like yep we got bamboozled I was
I was getting the hang of it they are
though you did great but it's definitely
a lot of like staying patient
trial-and-error max I feel like we did
not get that far into the story and we
already used up all of our time yeah
well you guys I hope you enjoyed
watching us fail as a child in a
hospital where we had a ton of fun and
tomorrow is Halloween so yeah maybe
maybe we can make up a day by doing two
streams somewhere like one of the
morning one in the evening mmm-hmm we'll
see we'll see you guys because I know we
did lose out on a day no extra life was
going on 72 hours and then we also had
some sponsored streams so zoo week yeah
busy week but we'll see tomorrow's
Halloween so let's see we can make the
best of it and man slender really
prepared me you're ready for anything
yeah I felt like I handled today so well
you did how's your hand no death grip on
the control you know I'm a little sore
here from yesterday but it definitely
didn't affect what I was doing today but
thank you guys so much pressure here
Richie joined me again thank you as
always or I'll see you guys tomorrow for
some more eight days of horror action
and have a good one we'll see you guys
later